let's talk about making a feature versus
on making a short I know you've done to
prior feature films one about religion
and politics in a small town i believe
and the other one about chronic fatigue
syndrome yeah the first one wasn't so
much about religion it was um it was
about changing demographics and
immigrant immigrant integration in small
town America Shelby welcome to show yes
and that was set in rural Tennessee and
started on the eve of the election of
President Obama and and the other one
was a more personal my first documentary
about mysterious illness chronic fatigue
syndrome and millions of people trying
to figure out what it what it is and
that journey so how is it because I know
you have many shorts also right and
you're in your portfolio so how is that
making a feature film versus a short I
realized it's going to differ with the
subject matter yeah access but but in
terms of the amount of energy and sure
output I love interspersing them I mean
I probably i'm working on a short now
that is related to the same issue or a
number of shorts but i like you know I
think it's tough after a three to four
year hall to just you know I guess it's
like having kids or something where you
know you know how quickly do you sort of
delve into it again sometimes you wait
and sometimes you don't but i love the
genre of short film even there are more
platforms now for it and I i think you
know efficient filmic filmmaking can I
think a lot of documentaries are too
long nowadays and in some ways and not
all need to be feature length length
films so I I love the I just love the
genre as much as I love short stories
versus novels so it's it's something I
love working with